please join in a moment of silence as
the 49ers Chiefs and National Football
League extend our deepest condolences to
the friends and families of those lost
this past week nine individuals whose
lives were cut short in Sunday's tragic
accident including Gianna and Kobe
Bryant Super Bowl 54 kept Kobe Bryant's
legacy alive on Sunday night featuring
multiple tributes to the late Laker the
NFL's big night kicked off with a
pregame tribute to Kobe and his daughter
Gianna honoring the pair as well as the
victims of the helicopter crash and Pro
Football Hall of Famer Kris Dolman with
a special moment of silence they will
never be forgotten
thank you players on both the 49ers and
the Chiefs stood on the 24 yard lines in
tribute to Kobe's number 24 Jersey
afterward the crowd inside could be
heard chanting Kobe's name and a subtle
moment you may have missed during
Jennifer Lopez and Shakira's halftime
performance a giant cross on the field
illuminated in yellow and purple the
colors of the LA Lakers and while many
fans in the audience were seen wearing
Lakers jerseys some of the players also
showed their love for the basketball
star on their cleats Emanuel Sanders of
the San Francisco 49ers was seen in a
red pair with Kobe's numbers 24 and 8
while Kansas City Chiefs player DeMarcus
Robinson warmed up in these yellow and
purple cleats with both numbers as well
leading up to the Super Bowl
et spoke with Shaquille O'Neal at Michel
Reubens fanatics Super Bowl party about
coping with the loss of his former
teammate okay so
this has been a lot this weekend for you
how are you processing everything Shack
what are you is it just a push through
mentality and on Friday night the former
Laker was celebrated again by his Lakers
family who spoke about the impact of the
Black Mamba it's a sad day the sad days
of you lose to someone like that I don't
think even to this day sometimes when I
wake up you don't believe it and someone
like that I've never experienced like
them this is so early such a young age
so it's gonna take a while it's not just
on one game or two game or two three
weeks and and maybe it's next year it's
something that we're gonna have to be
able to try to find a rhythm and a way
to be able to use it you can see a lot
of the clips from a lot of our practices
when me and Kobe or is kind of leading
the gang and leading the troops and you
could tell huh both of us are like
seeing which one is the alpha dog at the
point in time you knows but at the same
time got so much mutual respect there's
so much drift so much Drive the
I just kind of just watched and see what
he was able to do why he was great you
know why he's successful in this league
and the reasons why you know he was you
know one of the best players in it in
the world you know year after year after
the year so if I was able to learn a lot
from him and kind of just go through my
career in China you know go through the
lessons he taught me so I mean is
emotions it's tough you know the entire
memorial before a game is tough tough
for me to just to see and then you just
say hear his voice and just you know
have the common realization that you
know very long